The Joe Rogan experience. The mind,
everyone's mind is so different. You know,
there's some people that they
don't have that obsessed mind.
Their mind is like they're,
they're better off like you know,
running a country store somewhere.
Just being real friendly to people
that come in and of being a baker,
making good food for folks. Yeah.
That's their thing. That's their calling
and that, you know, that's perfectly
fine. It's the people, you know,
people did annoy the fuck out of me.
I love you.
What's you annoy the fuck out of
me is people that have no ambition,
no drive whatsoever.
I'm just happy not doing shit.
I always wonder about that.
I always wonder like,
what if I got them when they were little?
What if I got a hold of them when they
were little and just introduced them to
exciting things and rewarded them when
they did well and high five them and
hugged them. You know what
I mean? Like please change
reinforcement of positive goals and
reinforcement of positive experiences.
I think there's some people that just,
they never got any of that and everything
was just work and just drudgery and
they'd rather just lay around because
that is the alternative to work and
drudgery.
Wow.
Um,
I gave a speech and I'm talking about
obsession and being driven and always,
and you know, one of the questions
African music guys asked me, so, uh,
what if you know you,
what if you don't want to do anything,
you don't have any goals or upsetting?
Uh,
could you tell me how to get one?
And I was like,
fuck,
how do I tell this motherfucker his,
you know,
he wanted to learn. He said, he
born, he went, I want to find a goal,
but I don't know you. I
don't know yet. I don't know.
This is the first time I ever met you
and you're asking me how to give you,
uh,
an obsession or make him give you an I.
Only thing I can tell you
is find something. Do you
have anything that you love?
Is there anything that you love? Anything
that you'd like to do then, you know,
start there. Dude. It's
dark, dark. If you, if it,
if the person looks back at and you
said, no, not really. Then I'm like,
fuck this dude is irking the fuck you
mean it chose you don't have any fucking
thing the job. No. No.
I know some people that have nothing.
Yeah.
Some people it is nothing and there's
nothing absolutely in that, you know,
you Pete, I love you guys, but
um, he bugged the fuck out of me,
but fuck and just,
you don't have a cause or go or
nothing that really excites you,
that you really want to make a difference.
You just,
you're happy being blind,
frayed and fucking chance.
I just want to be at cod,
man.
I just worked the fucking car.
World needs cogs. Do you think that some
people like here's, here's a thought.
Like not everybody can be a
fucking psychopath right now.
Not everybody can be obsessed by things.
The world will be too insane and regular
stuff would never get done. Right, right.
You and I aren't getting
regular shit done, you know,
but how about being the best fucking
cock there is breast fucking Cadbury's,
man. I'm going to support the fuck
out of Joe wrote. Oh Man, I don't know
what people, I don't, I would like to,
I think one day we're going to probably
be able to experience this through
technology. I would like to know
how people think. Like I would not,
I would like to know like what is
going on in someone's head when they
experienced like some,
sometimes things will happen to you
in life and you're just in the worst
possible state of mind when it happens
and sometimes it's the best possible
state of mind and sometimes when
it's the best possible state of mind,
something that should be like
catastrophic like eh, it'll be all right.
You know like the person
who did it to you like,
look man I know you didn't mean to do.
It's all right, don't worry about it.
Take it easy. And then you just drop
it and you're like, feel good about it.
And then other times like fuck that guy,
I'm going to fucking kill that guy.
And it's all like, it's all in
like how were you wired that day?
Like, what, what's, how
are you coming into it?
You coming into this with a lot of stress,
you've got a lot of other
bullshit piling up in your life,
or are you coming into this fresh off a
heart transplant where you feel love for
the world and you and you have like a
new found enlightenment where you realize
like,
this is all bullshit,
all this nonsense and fighting
and arguing for nothing. Like why,
why you do you enjoy,
relax.
I appreciate Matt or distinct,
that's serious.
Have Passion for your
existence and what you enjoy,
what you truly love and your friends
and comradery and fellowship.
That's what it's all about.
Yeah. And I think, uh, you know,
they got a whole field,
the psychologists and psychiatrists,
that's their fealty and some of the worst,
uh,
some of the most mentally challenged
people I've ever met were psychiatrist.
I'm like, what though? Have
a theory about that. Yeah,
I have a theory about that.
I've theory about that.
That's very similar in my
theory about cops. You know,
I have a deep respect
for cops need to and uh,
I think it's an insanely difficult job.
Just same,
same feeling I have for soldiers.
Like you cannot expect someone to
just do that with no guidance and no,
no, you, you have to have an appreciation
for the stress they go through.
Every time a cop pull somebody over, this
might be the last moment of their life.
Every time they come to that window and
it's tinted and they don't know who the
fuck is in there and what kind
of warrant that guy might have.
They don't have any idea.
And we've seen videos online and cops
getting shot and people getting killed.
It fucking happens. And there everyone
they're dealing with is lying to them.
Everyone, they're dealing with
this. If you're a psychiatrist,
every day you're dealing with
people who are fucked every day.
Everyone's fucked up.
Everyone's in some,
some of their fucked up is nonsense and
you just want to grab them and shake
them by the call and get your
fucking shit together. Man,
the fuck is wrong with you. Come on.
You know there's something wrong.
Stop doing what you're doing stupid.
But you can't even say that.
So you have to go. So Mike, um,
uh, you know, uh, you're, you're,
you're still getting
tied up by that woman.
She still kicks in the balls because he
shouldn't have people who are into like,
if you imagine every day you
showing up and everyone's nuts,
everyone you work with, you know,
I'm very fortunate. I show up here,
I get to talk to nice people like you
hang out with great people like Jamie and
every, everyone's fun here. It's all nice.
My experiences on a daily
basis are very mostly positive.
I go to the comedy store, hang out with
comedians. I did you do to hang on.
What'd you do to guys?
It's fun experiences or good experiences.
Psychiatrists are just dealing
with crazy bucks all day long.
When I was, um, when I
was briefly in college,
one of the things that I was concentrating
on with psychology because I was
trying to find out what can,
I knew there was times when I fought and
I was very confident and I knew there
was times that her father was a nervous
wreck. And I was like, why? What is that?
That feeling of nerves were you scared
is very compromising. It fucks me up.
Performance. Yeah. I mean look, you,
you might get hit, you might lose,
you could happen. But to
dwell on that, it's crippling.
Like it gotta be able to
accept those consequences,
but you also have to not dwell.
So they have to be zen.
And so I was reading a lot of
psychology books and philosophy books,
a lot of Samurai books.
And um,
but one thing I realized in talking to
people that were like psychologist or
psychology majors,
like you're dealing with
fucked up people all the time,
especially psychiatrists. Oh, fuck people.
And then they're prescribing them drugs
like, hey, go get out. I gotta take this.
We'll get numbers.
Buddies. Like I was crazy.
He was crazy. Yeah. Very nice
cabinets. I think you get crazy. Yeah.
I think you get crazy dealing with all
those people all the time too, man. Yeah.
I mean,
if your day is blocked off,
you have your secretary and then
you've got patients all day long.
They're out of their fucking minds.
Very good point.
It's a terrible diet,
you know?